now did jenny from the block think that
she would be shutting down new york city
to premiere her documentary i'm nervous
but i'm excited and i wouldn't want to
do it any other place we're here
well jenny from the block looked pretty
confident to us in this daring tom ford
black velvet and mesh cutout gown
opening the tribeca festival with her
netflix documentary halftime out june
14th and while fiance again ben affleck
was busy in la shooting with buddy matt
damon j.lo proudly showed off that eight
and a half carat green diamond been
featured in the dock as well how full
circle of a moment is this for you
though it's a beautiful moment my life
is just beginning waiting for tonight
this is just the beginning for you a
half time it's half time champions are
made in the in the third and fourth
quarter that's when you win so i feel
like there's a lot of life ahead of me i
do think it's just halftime i want
something real
she's terrific i'm happy
her film is opening the festival i am so
excited for her she is like goals like
life goals
so many people are just obsessed with
this benefit 2.0 story because it's like
we all it's like you know your first
love
she met ben right on time she should not
have been with him earlier that other
time this is actually the right time
this is the best time of my life nothing
is more fulfilling to me than being able
to build a family
with someone who i love deeply and who
is just as dedicated to family and and
to each other as we can be this morning
on gma jlo gushed about ben as she and
grameen america's ceo announced an
initiative to provide more than 14
billion dollars in loans to latina
entrepreneurs i love the idea of the
future and what we can create
but i really just want to savor the
moment i just want to stay real present
in it as much as i can